comment tes amis l'émission avec les dix
questions
je vous ai soumise comme atout mais
inviter votre mot préféré qu'ils bedos
amour le mot que vous détestez mort
votre drogue favorite après ce le son le
bruit que leurs doses dès le son le
bruit que vous aimez le rire d'un enfant
et le son le bruit que vous détestez les
pleurs d'un enfant sur le sait les miens
votre juron gros mot blasphème favori
[ __ ] de dieu
homme ou femme pour illustrer un nouveau
billet de banque
paul loup sulitzer il a mérité je le
mettais que vous n'auriez pas aimé faire
flic la plante l'arbre où l'animal dans
lequel vous aimeriez être réincarné
je ne détesterais pas être un loup parce
que je pense à la fable de la fontaine
au loup et le chien le miel loup et
l'agneau
oui mais tant pis pour les avions alors
si dieu existe qu aimeriez vous après
votre mort l'entendre vous dire réveille
toi c'était pour rire
nous allons terminer cette émission bien
entendu par l'éclat meuse 10 question
que je vous pose à tous les deux
évidemment aujourd'hui alors fanny
ardant votre mot préféré tant pis
marcello lumière lumière le mot que vous
détestez ortin fisc votre drogue
favorite à l'eau chaude des salles de
bains dois le dire et cigarettes le son
le bruit que vous aimez l brute des
ciseaux dans les cheveux le treuil le
son le bruit que vous détestez les gens
qui mangent et en écoute on savait
qu'ils tirent du code qui mangent du
coton et samedi j'étais jeune je voulais
juste vous souffrirez les motos les
motos votre juron blasphème ou gros mots
favoris magath son contrat ça veut dire
quoi
mais je sais pas de traduire en français
moi j'ai jamais dit que c'est pas ce que
ça veut dire t'es sûr pour vous pas bon
et vous dieu géomètre dieux géants m oui
c'est un jardin suspendu dans la région
de la province
qu'est ce que les géomètres ils ont
détruit l'italie alors le grand mas il
vers dieu seul appelé géomètre deuxième
est un mou femmes pour illustrer un
nouveau billet de banque l'a fait qu'à
rabat et la fée carabosse
moi je voudrais mettre mon père je peux
être sentimental dans sa vie dans sa
villa et n'a pas vu passer beaucoup de
billets nous on a plus
à loger au de loi draps c'est quoi ces
traits je vise auprès de l'autre côté
mois mais le métier finir dont vous
n'auriez pas aimé faire bureau comptable
parce que je les fais je suis ce qu'ils
savaient de la plante l'arbre où
l'animal dans lequel vous aimeriez être
réincarné un la chèvre de monsieur
seguin de sa peine et enfin si dieu
existe qu aimeriez vous après votre mort
l'entendre vous dire et villers salut
l'artiste vous restez vous descendez où
l ascenseur et maintenant comme on est
petit peu en retard les dix questions
comme tous les invités à laure berthaud
et coup votre mon préféré
dans quelle langue parce qu'un art
français à savoir à savoir le mot que
vous détestez occuper votre drogue
favorite le tabac hélas le son le bruit
que vous aimez le silence le son le
bruit que vous détestez les silences
parfois votre juron gros mot blasphème
favoris on y revient messieurs il ya des
enfants à cette heure
il ya des enfants à la tv non non non en
tout cas mon père qui était personnes
tripoli disant jurons qui était la
miseria la misère alors parfois la
miseria la misère homme ou femme pour
illustrer un nouveau billet de banque
15 15 le métier que vous n'auriez pas
aimé faire l'interviewer assez gentil ça
laplante l'arbre où l'animal dans lequel
dans lequel vous aimeriez être réincarné
et je suis incertain entre une mouette
et un chêne immobilité où l'une peut
venir sur l'autre je peux pas choisir le
2 alors chen chen et enfin si dieu
existe qu aimeriez vous après votre mort
l'entendre vous dire mais pourquoi vous
meinau mais tellement souvent à la
télévision
foutez moi la paix on va tenter remis
ses missions avec d'abord le
questionnaire en faillite et repérer
votre mot préféré jean favier l'horizon
bien aux nanas le mot que tu détestes
je crois que c'était idolâtrie la guerre
car bien on met votre drogue favori
wagner château petrus le son le bruit
que que tu aimes
ouais c'est plutôt le son d'une paire de
draps sous un lit à baldaquin par un
soir de nuit pluvieuse
ah bon mois plus tôt le bruit des vagues
et le son le bruit que vous détestez et
motocyclettes dont on a enlevé le
silencieux - c'est le le rire du saumon
qui viennent casser la ligne de makala
mouline jurons gros mot blasphème
favoris au ça ça doit être moi c'est un
peu héréditaire depuis le grand père mon
père c'est toujours moi - cham ag
continue aussi s'est il disait quand il
était vraiment quoi la volaille de dieu
volailles de volailles de dieu joueront
gros mots parce que moi j'ai tout
simplement de votre cambronne bien un
mouvement pour illustrer nouveau billet
de banque
un nouveau billet de banque je crois
qu'on a dû oublier thurgovien pts et il
pensait alors là où des gros shows marx
gaucho mars le métier que tu n'aurais
pas aimé faire un gardien de cimetière
le métier j'aurais pas aimé faire
photographe au monde
il doit pas être payés souvent il ya
beaucoup plus de photos maintenant oui
autrefois il y en avait pas maintenant
il y en a et la plante l'arbre où
l'animal dans lequel vous aimeriez être
rien car mes chats chez les favier les
chardons le chardon bref peuvent
s'habiller pour pas être emmerdés
justement la personne n'approche pas
d'accord bon et si dieu existe
qu'aimerais tu après ta mort l'entendre
te dira tout à fait repérer voulez vous
êtes bon sommelier et alors si dieu
existe qu'elle vous riez vous après
votre mort l'entendre vous dire à vous
j'en fais j'espère qu'il me dira et à ce
soir un concert je vous ai rien avec
l'asse jean sébastien bach qui joue mais
décidément vous aimait beaucoup la
musique mais bon ah oui vraiment
beaucoup et sans honte oui bah non
questionné à fabrice pour terminer
baisser votre mot préféré mon mot
préféré c'est vraiment un seul vous me
limiter à un mot total
non mais vous faites vite un vrai
j'avais très très vite croquis le mot
vous détestez médiocre votre drogue
favorite la répétition sur une scène de
théâtre
le son le bruit que vous aimez la voix
d'un acteur immense d'une actrice
immense donc entre parenthèses j'ai été
servie alizés le son le bruit que vous
déteste le bruit que je déteste les
mobylettes qui vont très peu vite et que
les gars des blogs comme on appelle ça
rigolait ont dégonflé c'est à pau à pau
ou bayonne par exemple un énorme bruit
qui est une agression absolue où il
entend jurons gros mot blasphème
favorise tess de petites fientes femme
pour lui ce nouveau billet de banque
pour illustrer un nouveau billet de
banque je peux vous en donner deux
balzac pour les 500 francs 100 francs et
rhin et arthur rimbaud pour les 100
francs arthur rimbaud pour l'ambiguïté
de la fin de sa vie quand il travaillait
avec les noirs en afrique pour autant de
vous les mêmes pays ne voulais même plus
savoir ce qu'il avait écrit comme ces
sublimes et quelle qualité je n'aurais
pas aimé frère ben je vais faire un peu
de peine à ma maman mais j'aurais pas
aimé et de coiffeurs la plante l'arbre
l'animal dans lequel vous aimeriez être
réincarné la plante l'animal dans lequel
j'aurais été je regretterai incarner le
décès la question non non mais moi je
répète une pièce en ce moment moi je
dirais c'est très beau à ce qu'on voit à
nice avec les choses non plus mais non
les tours et les trucs qu'on les palmes
ou avait parlé parce que comme disait
paul valéry ils ont le ils ont ils ont
le sens de la chute
enfin si dieu existe si dieu existe qu
aimeriez vous après votre mort
l'entendre vous dire avoue fabrice
luchini et bien j'aimerais qu'il me dise
deux choses le droit à 2 oui oui
première chose dieu est amour donc tout
va bien je vomis les tièdes donc encore
une fois tout va bien et troisième chose
il y à une lecture de maître eckhart par
michel bouquet à 18h alors le
questionnaire fin d'émission ce qu'est
ce que ces dix questions sont posées à
tous les invités de référence qui
viennent dans cette émission de presque
depuis ses débuts alors voici ses dc10
question votre mot préféré où il dit
allen notre mot m'a fait rire world
mon préféré là non ça je peux pas vous
le dire à la télévision
j'aime pas à bon messi s'est dit lui
aussi si au contraire
non vraiment je ne peux pas pourquoi ma
mère ma mère regardent peut-être
l'émission on en entends je ne peux pas
elle est le mot que vous détestez à
bonjour votre drogue favorite favori que
l'aspirine le son le bruit que vous
aimez fns
le bruit ce que je préfère
où est peut-être un coup deux coups de
feu
ah bon et le coup de feu sur broadway et
et le son le bruit que vous détestez à
adam
je n'aime pas le son de la voix votre
juron gros mots ou blasphème favori m'a
fait froid
pourquoi quand vous êtes en colère je ne
suis pas comme ça quand je suis en
colère je suis très désagréable quand je
suis en colère quand vous n'aimeriez pas
vous n'aimeriez pas et je peux pas
prendre je peux pas prendre de risques
qu'une conne mais proche où m et être
cher m'entends dire ça non non non non
c'est trop violent
non non non non je peux pas vraiment pas
aimé c'est peut-être le premier mot que
vous vouliez pas prononcé à la première
question il ya ça même
certes il ya beaucoup d'autres mots
petit cousin aimait bien le métier que
vous n'auriez pas aimé faire oui jabbes
quel métier a good night by n'aurait pas
voulu que ce prêt jeune moine ou être
gardien de prison par exemple très bien
laplante l'arbre où l'animal dans lequel
vous aimeriez être réincarné
bonne question
être être réincarné en est proche
le pont en éponge oui mais pourquoi pour
gonfler côté c'était joli c'est sa
baisse nos ennemis les éponges n'a pas
d'ennemi patrimoine mais pourquoi pas et
la dernière question qui est plus
difficile si dieu existe si dieu existe
qu'aimeriez vous après votre mort
l'entendre vous dire à vous woody allen
hughes et bio je te pardonne
phil s'ils existent je pense que je
risque d'avoir de gros problèmes alors
le questionnaire votre famille votre mot
préféré la douceur mots que vous
détestez la calomnie votre drogue
favorite le chocolat au lait le son le
bruit que vous aimez les spas et des
rires des enfants le matin quand il
passe devant ma chambre et qui vont
prendre leur petit déjeuner ils sont le
bruit que vous détestez la lime à ongles
votre juron gros mot blasphème favori
merde
typiquement français là et or là c'est
d'ailleurs parce que là on n'a pas pu en
parler mais je me dire vous êtes le le
représentant vous êtes le député du
grand québec est une circonscription
très ouvrière et en même temps vous avez
fait toutes vos études ou de 30 ans se
passe au trocadéro dans le 16e
arrondissement à là il y avait un
personnage double j'ai appris énormément
que milliers le des gens m'ont apporté
beaucoup j'essaie de leur apporter mais
je trouve que la voix de jurons à mon
avis rassemble le trocadéro au grand
kevin merde mon avis il avoue fait la
liaison entre le alors homme ou femme
pour illustrer de vos billets de banque
jean jaurès le métier que vous n'auriez
pas aimé faire trafiquant
trafiquants c'est par amitié de plus en
plus ses abonnés du maître bonheur quand
même été promu ministre
laplante l'arbre l'animal dans lequel
vous aimeriez être réincarné cheval
sauvage un cheval sauvage as intéressant
préférez les chevaux sauvages qu'on peut
pas fait qu'on ne peut pas monter plutôt
que celui à la dimension de la crinière
et enfin si dieu existe qu'aimeriez vous
après votre mort lorient laurent fabius
nous entendre dire par dieu vient
assieds toi mon fils et dis moi ce que
tu voudrais faire dans cette période un
peu nouvelle qui s'ouvre à s'intéressant
tout de suite déjà donc le travail
l'ambition ambitions il sert à bercy ont
franchi les c'est assez incroyable des
temps de réponse très intéressant en
jargon étape le le questionnaire le
questionnaire alors robert badinter
votre mot préféré justice le mot vous
détestez racisme le but drogue favorite
le travail
le son le bruit que vous aimez la bague
bruit de la mer et le son le bruit que
vous détestez à le klaxon et le votre
juron gros mot blasphème favori merde
c'est pas mieux s'épanouir et gina
classique et vous n'avez jamais changé
je crois pas non aux classiques guidel
vous êtes finalement très classe et
hommes ou femmes pour illustrer un
nouveau billet de banque
j'étais sérieusement condorcet pour me
faire plaisir elisabeth badinter et puis
s'ennuierait peau faire
voulait pas du tout non mais je n'en
n'ai jamais voulu
oui au contraire d'abord alerté une
publicité folle assad s'était pas loin
de l'oeil ses bienfaits bon le métier
vous n'auriez pas aimé faire bourreau
avant 80 et aujourd'hui
fini s'est vite de la retraite
d'ailleurs je veillais ce qui est d'une
pension la plante l'arbre l'animal dans
lequel vous aimeriez être réincarné le
renard le renard parce qu'il veut
toujours être libres rappelé plus tôt
perdre là que je la coupe et que d'être
retenu dans le piège
le renard le renard dans une émission et
roter alors nous allons mais pas dit
déçu mardi j'attends et l'animal della
liberta pa luz et voilà et enfin si dieu
existe qu'aimeriez vous après votre mort
l'entendre vous dire avoue robert
badinter
tu as fais ce que tu as pu entre
questionnaire très bien le questionner
alors le votre mot préféré sur emmanuel
ya là ce qui veut dire en avant ce que
j'ai dit comme ça que j'ai dit ah bon
dieu mêmes mots que vous détestez jamais
charité dans la vie jamais faut toujours
courir chaque char nez et on est
toujours toujours vécu quant au cha cha
plus pas de stop mais votre drogue
oui c'est ça votre favorite d'autres
drogues favorite en ballon la lâcheté
schumann t
moi je pense que vous allez me répondre
jésus vous voulez quelque chose de
matériel la non nous on vous répond de
ce coup voulu un registre chose lors
l'astuce l'astuce pour malte et où j'ai
vu il n'y a rien de commun entre eux au
point de vue de quelque chose que j'aime
dans ma bouche c'est la sté spumante
beaucoup de champagne très bien si c'est
mona mon père ma vie ma force mon
enthousiasme c'est judas c'est juste le
son le bruit que vous aimez c'est le sa
levée reggina des moines de lérins
c'est très extraordinaire il le chante
le soin après conflit dans leur église
tout est au silence tout est sombre
la vierge est légèrement illuminé et le
salut aux rênes
tu as qu'est notre espoir c'est vraiment
l'humanité écrit était sûr que
finalement battu finira bien très bien
j'enregistre ça va ça va le son le bruit
que vous détestez alors là j'ai noté le
haut parleur pour un mort pendant le
haut parleur pour un mort si vous étiez
au caire vous comprendriez oui d'accord
ni sur celles pouvant pas oui parce que
je conçois tout à coup ça comment vous
êtes saisis
ça pue jusqu'à ligne le haut parleur
pour amorcer sa maman y'a rien alors ma
soeur j'excuse d'impôt cette question
votre jure au gros mot blasphème je ne
pense pas
espèce de charbon espèce de chameau
assez joli le père pascal du shamu en
afrique est un animal noble
c'est le plus grand compliment qu'on
puisse faire un homme c'est de lui dire
qu'à match est à dire chapeau mou femmes
pour illustrer un nouveau billet de
banque
pascal le métier que vous n'auriez pas
aimé faire sur un manuel chauffeur de
poids lourd donc à ce que j'ai connu des
chauffeurs de poids lourds qui sont
partis dijoux qui sont revenus dans leur
appartement
l'appartement vide la femme partie avec
le gosse jamais oublier ça et des
chauffeurs de pâles ou c'est un mauvais
mais bon la plante l'arbre où l'animal
dans lequel vous aimeriez être réincarné
le pas lui d'égypte n'y a rien de plus
beau de plus je ne sais pas
depuis artistique que le palm et
d'egypte qui laisse pour bêcher date at
elle à entonné pacha et enfin alors
c'est là que je vais pas je fais le tour
puis je reviendrai à vous donc la
dernière question évidemment elle est
circonstances comme un vendredi saint si
dieu existe qu'aimeriez vous après votre
mort l'entendre vous dire à vous paulo
coelho vous avez combattu le bon combat
fait le bon combat
oui du cri si différents que si dieu
existe moi j'aimerais qu'il dise
simplement enfin s'il avait la bonté
d'ajouter c'est la fête alors ce serait
parfait mais champagne que me dirait
asti spumante astiz comment alors jean
petit j'aimerais qu'ils me disent vient
pour la fête vient pour le festin vient
boire manger danser tout le monde est
invité ni compris les clandestins noël
copains bien j'allais un peu répété les
autres mais j'aimerais qu'ils me disent
attend encore quelques années et je
t'offrirai de l'asti spumante que dû
boire avec soeur emmanuelle
mais pour être plus sérieux puisque pour
moi la foi est un pari pari sur dur sur
l'homme
je pense qu'il me dirais tu vas gagner
ton pari n'est qu'il ajouterait je crois
en l'homme
c'est beau alors il vous sera alors que
si dieu existe alors je répète la
question si dieu existe soeur emmanuelle
ok d'accord
j ai dit vous même qui vous arrive de
douter non c'est vrai voilà si dieu
existe qu aimeriez vous après votre mort
que je souhaite le plus tard possible
vous entendre vous dire à vous dire à
dieu existe et il me dira vie dit il est
amené à vient au mac bien aimé et je lui
dirai je suis l'homme au bien-aimée
formidable ça vous êtes un personnage au
caire à mon avis sont pas embêtés agents
dans 20 ans
alors les chiffonniers ça je comprends
pourquoi vous avez les chiffres était si
populaire auprès d'eux alors maintenant
je comprends votre mot préféré
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui avec une apostrophe au
milieu le mot vous détestez un mauvais
sentiment décrit par un mauvais mot
concupiscence le son le bruit que vous
aimez c'est le son très discret des
pages que je tourne en lisant un livre
ou le sont aussi discrets du stylo sur
la feuille
laplante l'arbre où l'animal dans lequel
vous aimeriez être réincarné j'aimerais
bien être réincarné dans un cep de la
romanée conti
[Rires]
votre juron gros mots ou blasphème
favori oh [ __ ] au [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
toujours trois fois homme ou femme
pour illustrer un nouveau billet de
banque
michel bouquet dans l'avare de molière
enfin si dieu existe qu'aimeriez vous
après votre mort
l'entendre vous dire alors mr paille
vote
agde ou you do pas terrible je am sorry
my god bataille don't speak english
mais c'est vrai qu'on ne parlait pas
anglais il parle français évidemment
audio c1 c'est vrai que vous parlez pas
anglais et bien vous avez toute
l'éternité devant vous pour apprendre
l'anglais et je vais vous donner un très
bon professeur s'il vous plaît allez me
chercher sur william shakespeare of
course
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]